il avait peur que le convoi bloc
entièrement la capitale il avait sorti
le grand les grands moyens on a même vu
des charmes
il ya pire y est vraiment une des images
chocs vous avez vu sur les cheminées que
les choses se sont rapidement accéléré
que les tensions sont vite apparus une
image a vite fait le tour des réseaux on
y voit un conducteur qui refuse
d'obtempérer et d'avoir sa vitre être
brisés par les forces de l'ordre
regarder
[Musique]
eh oui
franchement gilles verdez affrontera
le groupe silicomp
souffre ça choquant la manière dont ils
ont été traités non mais j'ai été très
très révolté par le traitement de la
police par rapport à ces gens là un
dispositif qui me paraît hors de
proportion et je trouve sachant qu'en
france aujourd'hui et c'est très
malheureux et je suis très mal encaissé
alors ça délirant être les images soir
lors de la manifestation qui est
interdite les forces de l'ordre ont usé
de gaz lacrymogènes mais de nombreux
passants aux touristes présents sur les
chantiers se sont retrouvés au milieu
des fumées et même des restaurants
regarder
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est vrai quoi la wii moi j'ai été
choqué par le traitement médiatique
serre que comme pour les gilet jaune les
médias n'ont pas fait leur job au lieu
de parler du fond de la manifestation et
des revendications du mouvement et s'est
focalisée sur les quelques incidents qui
avaient il ya eu trente deux mille
manifestants il ya eu 90 cette
interpellation c'est 0,3 pour cent des
personnes qui étaient là et j'ai pas
retrouver ce ratio l'avant classement
médiatique on voit que des gens qui se
tapent dessus dès lors du match qui a
énormément tourner c'est ce policier qui
a braqué par un manifestant regard des
rassemblements non déclarés du coût des
forces de l'ordre à craon course
poursuite avec cette voiture qui
visiblement ne voulait pas s'arrêter
au total plusieurs centaines
d'interpellations
la plupart ce sont des automobilistes
qui bloquaient la circulation
ça fait des mois et des mois et des mois
qu'ils sont sous tension alors justifie
rien mais c'est vrai bon voilà ils
bloquent pour à cran et puissant mais là
c'est un délit de fuite non non non mais
là on arrête quand la police dit
d'arrêter mon
père d'origine mais la riposte doit être
proportionnée dérivés
c'est vrai que ce soit quand même et non
qu'est ce qu'il va faire alors quand une
voiture s'arrête pas gilles là mais
qu'est ce qu'il faut faire
c'est dommage c'est que c'était parti
bon enfant j'ai trouvé cette
manifestation c'était bon enfant tout le
monde se retrouvait un peu comme
interdites cg les jeunes
dit que c'était interdit échanges
l'elysée évidemment il sortait le champs
elysées donc forcément il y allait avoir
des problèmes et posé la question à tous
les commerçants déchanter alors maire du
côté des pressions aussi déploré une
certaine violence des manifestants s'est
lui ont dit certaines forces de l'ordre
ont été pris à partie leur garde
[Musique]
ça c'est pas du coup
sûr il y en a une qui a parlé du convoi
c'est encore sophia aram encore sur
france inter donc les donneurs de leçons
sont de retour vous allez voir qu'elle a
eu des mots très durs et est encore une
fois moi je trouvais voilà c'était dur
et pas drôle le problème c'est ça encore
une fois je rappelle un sophia aram
voilà rist un mec qui y voit qui ne
porte pas dans son coeur non compris
mais on est plutôt content voilà je vous
dis comme matt ils ont reculé à la fois
comme sophia aram dit du mal de vous
c'est que c'est bon vous êtes drôle
regardez à la facaci le convoi de la
liberté c'est vrai que c'est bien de 2,2
de se moquer de gens comme ça qui ces
deux et méprisant mais c'est méprisant
tu sais bien que ce vocale hors jeu vous
montrer mais c'est bien de se moquer de
gens comme ça quand on est
tranquillement
je dis pas que nous on est alors non et
on kiffe aussi voilà je le dis je me dis
toujours on est très très bien lotis
mais il ya des gens qui sont dans des
difficultés extrêmes et qui ont envie de
le dire est ce qu'on a envie de le faire
comprendre et qui ont envie de le faire
savoir on est dans une démocratie on a
le droit de manifester on a le droit de
dire qu'on n'est pas d'accord et c'est
vrai que sophie aram qui encore la
donneuse de leçons 1 voilà deux qui
étaient tranquillement certainement au
café de flore germain des prés en train
de siroter un chocolat chaud n'a pas
aimé que le convoi de la liberté la
dérange voilà pendant qu'elle prenait
son chocolat chaud voilà
pour elle
qui vous les convois de camions voulez
faites mais sans camion ce qui pose
quand même un problème de crédibilité
parce que sont les tracks occupé paris
avec cinq autos trois motocyclettes pi2
roulotte on s'est douté que ça n'avait
pas de chance de pogner votre affaire et
franchement sapad allure l'un roulait à
28 km heure dans une ville limitée à 30
c'est quoi ses yeux votre quand on voit
la tellement rien à voir avec se disait
qu'on finit par se demander si c'est pas
juste une caricature pour nous niaiser
le
voilà c'est vrai que c'est triste
non mais c'est tellement pas de rouge
médias - ya quelqu'un qui va faire une
chronique comme ça à côté de moi j'ai
dit non mais franchement je suis gêné
c'est vraiment le mot fort sophia aram
sur toutes ses chroniques cg non mais
vraiment elle me fait un peu de peine
parce que c'est gênant et surtout moi je
déteste le mépris et les donneurs de
leçons voilà il faudrait pas qu sophia
aram oublie qu'elle est payée par
l'argent du service public
par les francs soit pas qu'elle oublie
ça vous dit on allait oublier par les
convois de manuel a certainement payé
par les chantres par des gens
pour justement à défendre leur pouvoir
d'achat et à la lèvre a concerné par ça
puisqu'elle est au dessus et tant mieux
pour elle mais faut pas me faut pas
mépriser comme ça les gens c'est ces
gens qui te donne à bouffer il faut pas
quand même leur cracher dessus c'est
très bien mais franchement 19 au bout la
liste sinon beaucoup la de sébastien
insupportable mais vraiment on n'en peut
plus des donneurs de leçons comme ça le
convoi de la liberté moi je vous dis
voilà moi j'aurais ça mais après on peut
dire que ça a été une réussite
malheureusement jamais par un mépris de
classe toujours l'esprit et le combat de
la liberté je respecte ce nom se battent
pour leur liberté
peut-être lauriers de 10 ans et pour le
pire sacré plein de jour ni les cherry
on a énormément parlé des gilet jaune et
quand on l'a dit dans un foyer à la
dernière fois il y avait il y avait
monsieur lescure qui étaient là roland
lescure de la république en marche il a
dit les les gilet jaune ils nous ont
coûté des milliards mais nous ont coûté
les miens aussi parce qu'ils ont fait
ils ont fait avancer les choses je suis
désolé et gilet jaune ya énormément de
mesures qui ont été prises après des
filets jaunes alors bien sûr il ya les
sophie aram et d'autres qui les
critiques qui disaient gilet jaune il
nous emmerde pas mais ça ne peut pas
aller faire les boutiques le samedi
voilà alors c'est vrai que pour les
commerçants c'est vrai que c'est une
catastrophe et moi aussi je me suis mis
à la place des commerçants c'est vrai
que c'est compliqué pour eux mais un
moment ils ont un message à faire passer
et in fine ils ont fait passer un
message qui a aidé des plus démunis
jean-yves gilet jaune surtout qu'ils
vont pas là bas pour se marrer les gars
quand même ils font pas c'est pas
intentionnel d'aller déranger des
commerçants d'aller déranger des
magasins les rangs des restaurateurs les
gars ils sont là bas parce qu'ils n'en
peuvent plus de leurs vies ils sont au
bord du yen à plat qui sont au bord du
suicide il empêche qu il pète les plombs
et ils n'ont pas je vous dis mari et moi
je lui parlais de nombreux policiers qui
nous disent quoi ils nous disent ils me
disent moi ils me disent le convoi de la
liberté que soient les combats les
libertés le gilet jaune c'est des gens
comme nous on n'a pas eu des chiens sont
dedans et on aura peut être à des curés
oui je vous le dis vous croyez oui c'est
vrai donc voilà donc aujourd'hui je
crois que tous ces gens là qui était
samedi en soirée qu'ils ont rigolé que
ce soit les forces de l'ordre où les
eaux les gens du combat de la liberté
mais bon et tata et a une fille le lundi
matin qu' qui ont leur poids qui le rend
fou plein la gueule et qui les fait
passer pour des moins que rien et ça moi
ça ça ça passe pas quand je suis rentré
mois samedi soir tard de voyage donc je
suis allé voir parce que j'habite à côté
des champs elysées je suis allé les voir
et leur parler parce qu'il y avait
encore beaucoup de bordel je dois dire
il y avait et il se passer encore
beaucoup de choses les gens sont
extrêmement touchant le vrai drame ça
fait trois ans on se fait chier qui
n'ont plus d'argent que l'essence
augmente même si c'est le gouvernement
n'est pas responsable de l'augmentation
ces mondial du pétrole les prix du
pétrole vers les gens mais vous dites
recherche oui si tu veux et les gens
vivent difficilement je trouvais leur
contestation légitime et moi je
soutenais souvent les rares et c'est
vrai bernard il a rencontré ces gens là
parce qu'ils y habitent là-bas mais
l'erreur c'est de penser que c'est un
jeu pensé que c'est une manifestation
bon enfant et que ça fait que trois ans
ça fait pas que trois ans que les gens
ils souffrent ça fait bien plus
longtemps que trois ans et le prochain
quinquennat faudra vraiment se pencher
parce que l'on ils ont frais ils ont
fait les excuses que c'est pour le pass
vaccinale mais quand tu parler aux gens
là bas il y en a aucun qui parlait du
pass vaccinale il parlait du plein
d'essence à 110 euros 110 euros un plein
d'essence sur une voiture banale on
prend une laguna une peugeot c110 balle
un plein d'essence ça va s'arrêter à la
poussée n'y a pas de camion évidemment
il ya pas de camion puisque les camions
les taxis et récupère une taxe donc vous
vous êtes dit ça vous choque pas vous
que les taxis qui se mettra en grève il
avait un plein d'essence à 120 euros sur
une citroën c5 pas de taxis en grève
parce qu'ils sont pas concernés parce
qu'on leur donne des aides derrière il
faut pas penser que ça c'est un convoi
de la liberté comme ça qu'on a fait pour
rigoler c'est justice simplement il a
l'air aussi les pauvres et là c'est ce
que je te dis je te dire moi j'ai pas
dit qu'il galère est pas je viens te
dire toutes les professions comme ça on
doit se servir du transport bah ça ça
marche pas pour l'instant parce que il
ya vraiment un truc qui doit se passer
son prochain quinquennat quel que soit
le président afghan arrêté de penser que
les gelées jaune ou le convoi de la
liberté comme indissociables à tulle
dira c'est tu te diras à christiane
taubira mais à qui de droit et là tu
seras président parce qu'à un moment
donné il va pas mettre sur son tapis 107
ans ça a l'air de faire marrer encore
une manie son casse déclaré les gens et
les mecs c'est des présences et pas il
vient de vivre trace par la france pour
aller voir les champs-elysées comme ça
et se faire gazer c'est pas c'est pas un
jeu moi et moi je vois des gens tristes
dans tout ça nous on n'est pas concerné
pas raison on n'est pas concerné donc
voilà
c'est pas une raison c'est pas une
raison des
critiques et des traités comme des
bouquins cela
voulait dire un truc non mais je
t'entends raymond mais en même temps moi
je me dis que c'est dommage parce
qu'effectivement il avait des requêtes
hyper importante comme le pouvoir
d'achat par exemple et ils ont quand
même tout mélanger on a parlé du
fabricant de lentilles vague du complot
tout a été mélangé et malgré tout ça pas
été audibles et moi ce que j'arrive pas
à comprendre ce que tu dis c'est que
dans moins de deux mois on a quinze
candidats qui se présentent à l'élection
présidentielle ça va deux emoa poutou
parmi ces 15 là il y en a aucun qui est
susceptible de tomber en convenir tu
comprends puisque j'ai parlé du prochain
quinquennat et janvier genre et je
rajoute encore humide avant c'était
jusqu'à fin décembre pour s'inscrire sur
les listes si les gens entendent ils
peuvent encore s'inscrire sur les listes
c'est fini grave en cette fin décembre
alors tu veux tu un taudis rondeau ça tu
peux aussi potentiel demain tu peux
t'inscrire chacun des étages et bien
cette année c'est possible encore pour
taubira c'est même possible pour hidalgo
2% tout est possible c'est 4 à 10 ha
dont il a déménagé tu peux t'inscrire
sur les nids streep et je vais t'aimer
là bas j'ai déménagé alors merci